[Musique]
c'était le bordel
bordel qui ont mal été sous l'eau toute
l'année qu'ils aient eu des bons moments
comme des moins bons moments alors des
bons moments je parle des moments entre
équipes soutien à tout ça que je retiens
c'est que c'est que la gestion crise en
france c'est pas ça c'est que c'est qu'à
chaque fois on avait un train de retard
avec ce qui se passait ainsi aujourd'hui
on va le dit qu'on en serait là il ya un
an je l'aurais pas cru
tout simplement aujourd'hui c'est
compliqué la fatigue s'accumule
on tire pas mal sur la corde on a des
journées un peu à rallonge
voilà le coc vide et toujours 13 ans
puis je me fais suivre à côté depuis la
fin de la première vague tout simplement
parce que sicot logiquement c'était trop
violent et que je savais pas comment
remonter à un moment donné je me suis
dit c'est soit je trouve les ressources
pour me faire aider à côté soit je
m'arrête
or baldwin de rien on a un peu notre
fierté de soignante c'est dire que bah
on va pas laisser les patients tout seul
on va pas laisser les collègues tout
seul un trop plein du fait de
l'épuisement général c'est ça devient
compliqué et malheureusement il ya aussi
beaucoup de collègues qui sont dans ce
cas là où ouais on est sur le fil du
rasoir tous les jours on est déjà
content d'arriver à se lever le matin
pour aller travailler
je pense que ça va appris beaucoup de
choses sur moi-même je pense que c'est
le cas aussi de pas mal de mes collègues
je pense qu'il en a qui vont ressortir
traumatisé pour ma part je fais tout
pour que pour que tout se passe bien
dans les mois et les années à venir mais
mais voilà c'est quand même c'est quand
même une expérience que je souhaite à
personne mais maintenant que je les ai
vécu voilà ça a appris des choses sur
sur nos capacités en tant que soignant à
tenir sur la durée